we begin our midterm election coverage
tonight with new insight on some of the
key races in this fall's midterm
elections it's the first of many stories
on the hottest contest leading up to
November correspondent Peter Doocy looks
at new information on the balance of
power if Democrats are going to turn the
Senate blue this fall they've got a
heavy lift because Republicans are only
defending eight seats Democrats and
independents who sit with them 26 to
tilt the chamber Democrats all need to
win then two Republicans need to lose
and incumbents include ten Democrats who
represent states President Trump won the
Democratic Senatorial Campaign Committee
says that Senate Democrats faced a
challenging map but Republicans are
facing expensive and divisive primaries
and an electorate that is repulsed by
their agenda but the National Republican
Senatorial Committee is trying to cast
the most vulnerable as very progressive
telling Fox that these red state
Democrats voted against the President's
agenda at every turn and have zero
explanation for why they sided with
Elizabeth Warren in voting against
President Trump's tax plan even the
Democrats running in these races are
trying to figure out a message that
isn't too critical of Trump while trying
to win over enough of that Democratic
base brand new Fox News Power Rankings
have four seats leaning democratic Ohio
Pennsylvania Nevada and Montana where
Trump won by 21 two states are leaning
Republican Indiana and Tennessee where
bob Corker is rethinking his retirement
then there are the five toss ups Arizona
Missouri North Dakota West Virginia and
Florida where President Trump has
already endorsed outgoing Governor Rick
Scott for the seat November's 36
governor's races represent a ripe
opportunity for Democrats 21 contests
are competitive and Democrats have an
edge in 15 the issues are different
they're not running on federal issues
they've had a different governing style
and they're not tied inextricably to
Donald Trump or Republicans in Congress
in the house where Democrats need to
flip 24 seats to win control Democratic
candidates have a six and a half point
edge on a generic ballot but they're
counting on a different number to carry
them president Trump's approval 38.8%
Democrats have not yet come up with a
unifying message
what are they going to say to the
American people other than we don't like
Trump
unfortunately for Republicans that might
be enough another pillar of the
Democratic strategy is to criticize the
tax reform bill the same tax reform bill
that Republicans think is their biggest
advantage I've obtained internal RN C
polling that shows most voters in seven
swing states believe the tax bill will
benefit them Brett
Peter thank you